[Music]  easter egg known as the nectar of the  gods honey is not only a sweet product  largely appreciated by adults and  children such as his group attending a  honey fest near yaz in romania this  natural substance also contains  antioxidants minerals and enzymes that  have many potential health benefits and  can be used for medical applications  according to experts  medical honey is also a medicine  not only does it contain compounds that  give us energy but its structure also  carries a whole series of other  biologically active compounds that can  cause beneficial effects on health  benefits  polyphenols and different types of  proteins that come from bees  and that simply have a natural  antibiotic effect  [Music]